heute wollen wir mal etwas über deutsche
politiker erfahren ihr alle kennt
wahrscheinlich angela merkel viele
kennen jedoch nur angela merkel
und wir wollen einfach mal gucken welche
politiker sind in deutschland eigentlich
beliebt los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unsere frage ist heute wer ist ihr
deutscher lieblingspolitiker das ist
eine schwere frage habt ihr einen
lieblings politiker oder eine lieblings
politikerin ich nicht schwer
habt ihr ein lieblings politiker eine
lieblings politikerin
ich sehe ich gar nicht die politik
ehrlich gesagt lieblings und politiker
schließt sich aus welche deutsche
politiker magst du zurzeit am besten
das ist eine schwere frage das kann ich
so pauschal überhaupt nicht beantworten
weil die das ist ein ganz differenziert
betrachten also keine klare antwort ich
würde mir spontan sagen der
bundespräsident steinmeier ja warum
ist gesetz sympathisch hat gute
ansichten und vertritt die
bundesrepublik irgendwie würde ich für
mich war jetzt bei seinem auftritt in
israel fand ich schon immer ganz gut hat
er gut gemacht irgendwie in denen er mit
und nicht ganz so schlimm findet
ströbele wirklich gern ja warum
und das sehr authentisch und sich treu
geblieben die ganze zeit dennoch aktiv
dafür hat sich ein bisschen
zurückgezogen
ich habe keine wobei doch wenn es ums
entertainment und um die rhetorische
expertise geht dann nach wenn ich also
also die inhalte ist mir aber ein
da möchte ich mich klar distanzieren
aber ihre tore
die iss wird sich spricht er denn der
weiß wie man seine gegner humoristisch
aussehen kann welche deutsche politiker
mögen sie ja ich mag angela merkel ich
kein problem mit den mag ich noch ich
mag olaf scholz
wer ist das was macht er und warum warum
also erstmal hat natürlich hier hat ein
bisschen charisma hatten bis nach
ausstrahlung fehlt sonst ein bisschen
gerade in der politik findet also mir
gefällt habe ich schon ganz gut wo sie
sagen wer ist das und was macht robert
habeck vorsitzender der grünen mit
vblock zusammen und was macht er gut ist
also ich finde der hat positionen
geäußert in letzter zeit die glaube ich
ganz viele menschen mit deutschland
verstehen nachvollziehen können und
viele andere parteien machen sehr viel
aber vor allem beschäftigen sich mit
sich selber auch und das ist bei den
grünen derzeit eher nicht so und deshalb
glaube ich ist das team in grün im
moment sehr überzeugt welche deutsche
politiker mögen sie also eigentlich nur
frau merkel ja sie ist beliebt obwohl
sie auch umstritten ist ja an ihren
politischen entscheidungen vielleicht
aber ich finde sie von ihren soft skills
her wirklich ansprechend als
wenn unser motiven naja so würde ich
nicht behaupten sondern ich finde die
frau ausgesprochen intelligent und was
ich sehr schätze ist ihre besonnenheit
in vielen dingen die man oft ankreidet
sie sei zu langsam
ich finde das gut die deutschen legen
ich finde den steinmeier finde ich gut
warum ein bundespräsident ich finde dass
er einer von den letzten diplomaten ist
tatsächlich was heißt dass er sein
diplomat der glaube ich sehr gut sich
auf andere einlassen kann auf andere
kulturen und andere meinungen und seine
meinung tatsächlich gut vertreten kann
auf eben besagte diplomatische art und
weise merkel ja ja warum
ja weil die einfach
die bleibt einfach sind die bleibt war
schon immer da die wäsche lieber genau
die commons vertrauen ja das ist schon
eine wichtige frage muss man sagen
und ja das ist sie beeindruckt und was
man da ist ihr mich nicht für politik
haben daher ist es also politik bin ich
einfach langweilig genau so mag sie nur
weil sie ist wie ein spiel genau es ist
einfach stabil
wie wäre es mit merkel ich werde sie
jetzt als frau ein starkes vorbild und
auch als kanzlerin hat sie einen guten
job gemacht aber sicherlich auch bei ihr
kann man sich an verschiedenen
politischen positionen daran stoßen und
dran streiten aber grundsätzlich ist sie
macht sie einen guten job als
politikerin ja und aus der aktuellen
bundesregierung wärs ja am
sympathischsten
herbert wehner leider schon lange her
und kein aktuellen mehr wirklich nicht
also die aktuelle politik riege
überzeugt nicht
nein was braucht denn ein guter
politiker im zweifelsfall charakter und
entsprechend tatsächlich so gut wie jede
politiker aktuell ab zumindest die in
der ersten reihe
angela merkel ist nicht einfach noch nie
gewesen
heiko maas um gottes willen was seehofer
ja jetzt wird jetzt immer bis jetzt
weiterhin schlimmer oder also wirklich
nicht nein tut mir leid also sie konnte
sich sehr gut verkaufen wie sieht es aus
mit heiko maas also die frage muss schon
konkreter sein magst du den ich kenne
ihn persönlich nicht aber als politiker
halte ich nichts von ihm
seehofer ebenso angela merkel
muss weg dann aus wird heiko maas den
wir heiko maas beliebig und wie sieht's
aus dem horst seehofer weniger beliebt
ja wir kommen aus bayern aber es hilft
nicht was braucht wenn ein politiker die
es jetzt noch nicht gibt was pad sollte
der denn haben um einen dein lieblings
politiker zu werden
tag da und prinzipientreue aber wie
gesagt auch das schließt sich ja bei
politik oft aus also auf
gezwungenermaßen weil er durch diese
ganze kompromissfähigkeit und
kompromisssuche aufgezogen wird manchmal
prinzipien über bord zu werfen und
deswegen weiß ich nicht ob man durch die
ganzen kompromisse die man machen muss
seinen prinzipien immer treu sein kann
wer hat heutzutage größten einfluss auf
deutsche politik in der deutschen
regierung die automobilindustrie
generell die industrie die industrie
noch mal die industrie die bürger eher
weniger würde ich sagen und ich wähle
die partei die partei ist das gut
das ist auch so ein fall die sind auf
jeden fall sind sie großartig in dem was
sie machen dass sie von sich reden
machen dass die partei auf einmal wieder
so in den öffentlichen raum politikerin
öffentlichen raum bringen
aber es ist auch viel quatsch dabei aber
das korrespondiert mit meinem für ihren
segel wir hoffen ihr habt heute etwas
neues erfahren über deutschen politiker
und deutsche politik wenn ihr mehr zu
dem thema wissen wollt empfehlen wir
euch auch unsere podcast episode über
deutsche politik tief verlinken wir hier
unten und ihr solltet natürlich weiter
deutsch lernen mit diesem vokabular und
den ausdrücken von heute
das könnt ihr als mitglied von easy
german da bekommt ihr nämlich jede woche
transkripte vokabel listen interaktive
übungen zu unseren videos und zu unserem
podcast
all das findet hier weil patchen und wir
hoffen dass ihr wieder dabei sein
nächste woche abonniert unseren kanal
und wir sehen uns nächsten sonntag
wieder
[Musik]